hallo Kinder hier ist wieder eure
Meinung und willkommen zu diesem neuen
adventskalender auspackvideo heute
machen wir einen ganz tollen
Adventskalender auf den ich mir als Kind
schon immer gewünscht habe aber nie
bekommen habe weil meine Eltern
Sparfüchse waren und lieber ihr Geld für
ein neues Haus ausgegeben haben sorry
dieser Seitenhieb musste sein denn ich
wollte schon immer einen Playmobil
Adventskalender haben ich habe ihn schon
damals in der Werbung gesehen entdecke
die neuen playmobil-adventskalender ganz
leise hinter jedem der 24 Türchen steckt
eine original playmobil-überraschung
Playmobil gehört zu den OGS was
Adventskalender angeht die haben schon
vor Jahren damit angefangen und den
Playmobil Adventskalender hatten alle
meine Freunde die haben dann ihr kleines
Weihnachtsdorf da aufgebaut und meine
Mutter hat's mal wieder vergessen einen
zu kaufen und dann einen zwei Tage
später von Aldi geholt
und das könnte möglicherweise der Grund
dafür sein dass ich dieses Format
überhaupt gestartet habe damit ich meine
Kindheitsträume endlich leben kann
dieser Adventskalender kommt natürlich
nicht nur so sondern mit einem Setting
ich freue mich so sehr darauf sehr
komplizierter als der Rituals Kalender
im letzten Jahr aha ja nee ja ja
kleine Backstube und da ist so draußen
ich werde draußen ist dann der
Weihnachtsmann und bevor ich jetzt in
diesem Video noch 300 Mal Playmobil sage
dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert und
jetzt alle dieses Video ist nicht
gespannt und jetzt Kinder schauen wir
was ist in Türchen Nummer eins
ich habe dieses Mal nicht mal lange
Fingernägel
das ist eine Kindersicherung nur Kinder
können es aufmachen haha Türchen Nummer
eins wer erwartet mich hier einmal kurz
nach den Preis sagen ne 25 Euro würde
ich für mein Kind ausgeben und jetzt
schauen wir was drin ist bei diesem
Kalender oder bei Playmobil und Lego und
allen möglichen muss man ja sagen
Plastik mit Plastik verpackt ne in
Türchen oh oh oh
die sieht aus wie ich in Türchen Nummer
eins ist einmal Vanessa und Vanessa ist
in der Backstube und Vanessa hat hier so
eine kleine Kochschürze wow so würde
Vanessa aussehen wenn sie sich ein
basket schneidet aber sie kriegt ihre
Haare zurück okay dann kommt mal Vanessa
in ihre Backstube ne denn das ist das
was Vanessa am meisten liebt Türchen
Nummer zwei die Gestalten diese
Adventskalender Folge jetzt einfach ein
bisschen kindergerecht also falls ihr
Kinder könnt schickt den dieses Video
auf Ihr iPad in Türchen Nummer zwei
echte Keksausstecher wow da haben wir
ein Engel die ungefähre Form von
Weihnachtsmann von dem elf und hier von
einem Weihnachtsmann so süß und ich weiß
nicht genau was das ist diese zwei Teile
und soll sie so ineinander stecken naja
und dann hat also warum gibt es das
nicht einfach als Ganzes glaube das ist
nämlich so um hier in dieses Gesicht
kannst du in alle Gesichter oh also das
sind ja ein Engel
11 und Weihnachtsmann und dann kannst du
den immer das das Playmobil Gesicht
reindrücken Türchen Nummer 3 was
verbirgt sich dahinter
Rätsel eine kleine Küchenzeile ja dann
steht wieder dahinter okay
Türchen Nummer vier ich weiß wir haben
gerade September Oktober aber dieser
Kalender versetzt mich so in
Weihnachtsstimmung
ich werde dieses Ding nie wieder finden
Playmobil hat schon seit Jahren dafür
gesorgt dass in Kinderzimmern
so kleines Zeug rumfliegt also ihr
werdet es nicht glauben Leute nee
bastelan gibt es doch gibt es glaube
schon ja man spoilert sich ja voll wenn
man das anguckt das muss man immer die
Eltern anschauen ne und das ist für den
zweiten Aufsatz ich glaube es nicht es
ist eine kleine KitchenAid also hier
hast du den ersatzaufsatz da oben kommt
dann natürlich der Knethaken weil wir
wollen ja Plätzchen backen ich hoffe ihr
könnt was erkennen dann ist da die
kleine Backschüssel drin und dann könnt
ihr das so umdrehen und dann ist das so
das Rührgerät also drin wow hey kleine
KitchenAid ich liebe es ich weiß ich bin
fast 30 aber ich kann ich kann nicht
anders Türchen Nummer fünf na klar
Rührschüssel die sind in der
Weihnachtsbäckerei es ist Nikolaus es
ist ein Kinder Adventskalender Kinder
wissen wann Nikolaus ist weil sie im
Kindergarten Nikolaus Wiedersehen und
morgens ein Stiefel haben mit Schokolade
im Schuh also manche Kinder haben das
andere haben sowas nicht bekommen ja
okay deswegen muss was Schönes
nikolausmäßiges drin sein oh na klar
was ist an Nikolaus drin natürlich und
der Nikolaus hat seine Liste dabei denn
der Nikolaus seine Weihnachtsmann
das ist der Nikolaus und der kommt aber
der steht hier der hat im Haus nichts zu
suchen nur am 24
Nummer 7 befindet sich wieder mega viel
kleiner als da freut sich der
Staubsauger
zusammensteckt okay
Anleitung also das ist hier so ein
Sticker und das klebt man auf dieses
komische weiße Ding rein und dann hat
man so sein kleines Plätzchen Rezept und
dann gibt's dann mein Gott verdammt
süßen Adventskranz acht oh wir kriegen
Gesellschaft dieses kleinen Zeug macht
mich wirklich es macht mich nervös guck
mal wie winzig also kein Wunder soll
immer überall steht erst ab drei und so
dass man sich das nicht in die Nase
schiebt aber ich glaube ich habe mir
ständig irgendwas davon in die Nase
geschoben ich gebe dir den Namen
Lieselotte und Lieselotte hat sogar
ihren eigenen ja damit sie mit backen
kann weil sie sonst zu klein ist sie
wäre viel zu klein also hat sie ein
Hocker und dann kann sie mithelfen
ich habe nie eine Hocker gehabt
entwickelt sich hier echt zu so einer
Therapiestunde Türchen Nummer 9 mein
Lieblingstierchen ist einfach
riesengroß als ob Playmobil das gewusst
hätte
das ein Plasma Fernsehen aber das ist
glaube ich doch eher ein Ofen
oh so und dann machen wir natürlich auch
das Ding hier zu und hinten und dann
kommen dann auch Schubladen rein ich
werde nicht mehr uns dazu gleich noch
ein Backblech gibt ne ich hoffe es kommt
dahin natürlich ist am 9 Türchen ist ein
Backofen drin weil ich so gerne backen
oder haben wir wieder Sticker okay also
ich habe hier so Sticker so Weizen drauf
weil wir Mehl haben ich Flip Ahaus und
Eier ey pressure ist on es kriegt doch
kein Kind denn das kannst du mir doch
nicht erzählen
Nummer 11 ich habe das Gefühl ich sitze
hier schon seit Stunden jetzt wird's
echt fies also einen kleinen Schneebesen
Nudelholz was ich wirklich drehen kann
komm das bekommst Du ich sage euch wenn
ich das als Kind gehabt hätte hätte ich
jeden Tag ausgepackt dann machen wir den
Teich ich weiß jetzt nicht wozu man bei
Playmobil
Schnitzel hacken
mir gefällt diese Konstruktion nicht
ganz ich finde sie ist ein bisschen zu
wackelig also klar was sollen sie sonst
mitbringen aber vielleicht irgendwas
stabileres weil die Figuren das fällt ja
dann natürlich irgendwie alles um Nummer
12 natürlich haben wir ein Backblech und
ich wette mit euch das ist in diesem
gottverdammten Ofen reinpasst na klar
kann unser Backblech im Backofen sein
Nummer
13 natürlich also erstmal tolles Pferd
aber wir wissen doch alle dass das mit
dem Rentier stattfindet diese ganze
Geschichte
Weihnachtsmann Nummer 14 in der 14 ist
viel also wir haben einen Jungs
Hans-peter Peterson und der hat
natürlich eine Mütze dabei in dem
schönen anthrazit weil er stylisch und
will nicht frieren und die hat er
natürlich auch wieder zwei Ersatz
Ärmelchen der hat da so Dinger an den
Arm hier die muss ich gerade befestigen
und jetzt kommt das absolute Highlight
hier sind vier Schneebälle und jeder
weiß dass man so ein Schneeball hält oh
ja wir sind schon bei Türchen Nummer 15
ich bin so gespannt
toll fühlt sich hier mal so ein bisschen
die nature zwei Hasen wieder im Schnee
rumstopfen Nummer 16 und natürlich ne ja
darf ja nicht fehlen eine kleine Möhre
für die Nase hallo neue Freunde ich bin
Olaf na klar eine Schneeschaufel es ist
doch
super 17 ist das also irgendwie kleine
Gläser mit ach da kommt noch was dazu
aber
natürlich haben wir wieder Sticker haben
wir hier so ein kleines Gläschen mit so
einem kleinen Deckel es ist wirklich
winzig das Zeug da kommen die Erdbeeren
drauf weil das irgendwas mit Erdbeer
drin Erdbeermarmelade Erdbeer
Kakaopulver scheißegal
toll und in dem ist Milch drin klar
Streusel sind hier drin Glas mit
Streuseln tada Nummer 18 hier sowas
rausgeflogen was so ein Gummi Ding ist
bevor ich mal auf damit haben wir hier
oh
was das andere Blech ist ja dagegen ein
Witz das nenne ich mal ein keksblech ne
und die kann man sogar rausnehmen und an
seine frisch ausgestochene Plätzchen auf
sein Blech legen und dann natürlich ab
in den Ofen damit also hier kann man ja
richtig spielen oh 19 auch wieder größer
denn
das ist doch der tolle Schlitten meine
Pferde Freundin anni wüsste jetzt wie
das heißt es ist ein Hüftgürtel aus
Sticker ja natürlich gibt's das dicker
weil der sieht doch ganz traurig aus das
wird jetzt hier drauf geklebt tolles
Design Weihnachtsmann Nummer 20
natürlich der Sack vom Nikolaus
[Musik]
der Sack vom Nikolaus mit ein paar Brief
drin 21
oh toll das ist drin und ihr wisst alle
was es ist ein Geschäft
und Nummer zwei der Countdown zu
Weihnachten wird kürzer wir sind beim 22
Dezember man hat schon richtig Bock auf
Weihnachten die Ferien haben glaube ich
jetzt schon angefangen oder fangen jetzt
an und man hat wieder ein hoffen Plastik
in der Hand was ist das okay nicht
zusammen ey das ist
ich glaube das sind kleine Geschenke und
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein
kleiner Alien Panzer dann ist hier noch
so ein Controller weil Kinder mögen
zocken und ein Mikrofon die Geschenke
die der Weihnachtsmann gebracht hat ein
Alien Panzer 23 vorletztes Türchen
morgen ist Weihnachten und wir bekommen
zwei Eichhörnchen natürlich ich habe
letztens in Berlin ein Eichhörnchen
gesehen das ist direkt neben unserem
Tisch immer wieder den Baum rauf und
runter geklettert ist total nicht
beeindruckt war von den Menschen die da
saßen also ich weiß nicht ob das so ein
typisches Berliner Stadt Eichhörnchen
ist aber wir waren sehr beeindruckt das
hat sich kurz angefühlt als ob man im
Zoo gewesen wäre und nun meine Damen und
Herren der Moment auf dem wir gewartet
haben dass 24 Türchen es ist Weihnachten
ich renne zu meinem Adventskalender ich
bin hoffentlich 8 Jahre und nicht 28 und
ich mache ihn auf und es befindet sich
darin jawoll ihr könnt auch anders sein
ein Tannenbaum mein Tannenbaum
natürlich mir ist gerade der Stern hier
oben abgefallen aber natürlich kann man
den auch raus und reinstecken ihr habt
ihr den Tannenbaum aber das ist ein
Tannenbaum für draußen deswegen ist er
so vollgeschenke von diesem Tannenbaum
jetzt nicht was es nicht ganz mein
Geschmack die Farben lila blau und weiß
aber es fügt sich wunderbar in dieses
tolle Bild ein also wie soll ich diesen
Kalender bewerten Leute es ist doch ganz
klar der ist absolut scheiße nein Spaß
wenn man ein Kind ist oder in meinem
Alter und traurig darüber dass man sowas
nie gekriegt hat dann ist es ein toller
Kalender also falls jemand hat der auch
immer sich ein Playmobil Adventskalender
gewünscht hat dann kaufe ihn den und
dann verschenkt an Kinder die wirklich
damit spielen werden es wäre schon crazy
wenn ich damit spielen würde es wäre
nicht schlimm man kann also aber ich
finde bei Lego da muss man wenigstens
noch was bauen und ein bisschen kreativ
sein und eine Anleitung folgen wenn ich
jetzt mit Playmobil spielen würde ja
aber es hat mir mega Spaß gemacht den
aufzubauen es hat komplett meine
Erinnerung außer Kindheit alles noch mal
hoch geholt und ich wäre sehr sehr
glücklich gewesen hätte ich den damals
bekommen jetzt
schenke ich ihn an meine Nichten und
Neffen oder verlosen an euch wir werden
sehen
bis dann eure malwanne so und das
nächste Mal gibt's dann wieder saufen
mein Image steht hier auf dem Spiel